movies are not the only thing marvel
fans have to look forward to it seems a
key avenger is getting their own
single-player game that plus
multiverse's updates on today's gamespot
news
it seems wakanda forever truly means it
because after the release of the film
will be reportedly getting a black
panther video game hot on the heels of
the mcu film's emotional trailer jeff
grubb of gamespot's sister site giant
bomb has revealed a few details on this
early in development title the game
codenamed project rainier is said to be
coming from a brand new studio based in
seattle founded by former monolith
productions vp and studio head kevin
stevens published under electronic arts
under stevens monolith productions
created the two open world lord of the
rings titles shadow of mordor and shadow
of war and that studio is now working on
a wonder woman game that was revealed at
last year's game awards two words that
define that wonder woman type will also
pertain to black panther single player
and open world grubb claims that the
game will act as an origin story the new
black panther working to assume the
mantle soon after the passing of its
previous bearer in nearly every popular
iteration of the character that is the
passing of the mantle from wakandan king
to chaka to his son t'challa but grubb
could not confirm if that will be the
case in this game perhaps this black
panther game is set in the past or the
future and follows one of t'challa's
ancestors or predecessors respectively
unfortunately don't expect to learn any
further details of this game anytime
soon as grubb claims it is in very early
development to while away the time until
more black panther video game news maybe
jump into the multiverse's open beta
which starts tomorrow after a week of
early access despite being available to
a limited number of people the game has
proved incredibly popular over the last
week according to eventshub.com since
the launch of the game in early access
the platform fighter has an average of
over 38 000 steam players online at any
given time and an all-time peak of over
61 000. that average is higher than the
near 29 000 average of the 13 next most
popular fighting games on steam from the
last month of course multiverse's
success can be attributed to the fact
that it is a taste of an upcoming
release plus the very robust marketing
campaign warner brothers has put behind
it including partnering with streamers
to promote the game but even still these
numbers are very impressive considering
that it wasn't available to everyone
with early access now being lifted it
stands to reason that concurrent play
account will only increase particularly
as the open beta will be adding lebron
james to the roster now you might be
very confused as to why lebron james but
this is lebron james the character from
space jammer new legacy not the actual
basketball player lebron james much like
buzz lightyear and lightyear was the
space explorer that the toy buzz
lightyear was based off of i hope that
clears things up the best way to play
the multiverse's open beta might be on
xbox which is getting an awesome stealth
update that cuts the series x and s boot
times by around 5 seconds this is thanks
to a shorter boot up animation sequence
that is now available to xbox insiders
of course with a 4 second boot animation
that means if you drop a piece of food
on the floor at the exact time you turn
on your xbox and the boot animation
completes you still have a full second
to pick it up but i'm sorry if it's
after that you have to discard the food
and that is the law alright everyone
that is it for today's gamespot news
thank you so much for hanging out with
me and we'll see you tomorrow